stick to the basics we have a big thing  of the best part is no part so you stick  to your basics in terms of get a good  MMC marketable candidate take it to  Market there's people who will spend  however long on LinkedIn post if you're  building a market that's like the sexy  stuff that comes later stick to the  basics the foundations good  qualifications make sure you're asking  that extra question questions that you  might not really like the answer to make  sure they're asked retain all the  information take them to Market that's  how we would that's how we won in in the  Life Sciences Division and obviously  we're not saying we we own the life  sciences division Market but we we got  into like one of the most prestigious  companies in the UK through Harry  filling a position that they had open  for nine months Harry filled in two  weeks the recruitment mentors podcast is  proudly sponsored by vincere and the  award-winning Source breaker